the organizers of a right-wing protest
in charlottesville virginia will go on
trial this morning more than four years
after that demonstration turned into a
deadly riot
ten plaintiffs are suing about two dozen
organizers of the unite the right rally
claiming they violated their civil
rights and are responsible for their
physical and emotional injuries jeff
begays is at the federal courthouse in
charlottesville jeff good morning
good morning we are expecting
riveting opening statements today with
the plaintiffs arguing and trying to lay
out a case that demonstrates that this
was a conspiracy that led to racially
motivated violence while on the other
side the defendants will argue that this
was not a conspiracy
and that they deserve to be cleared
of breaking any laws
on wednesday jurors in the
charlottesville riot civil trial were
sworn in the defendants members of white
supremacist neo-nazi groups
who in 2017 marched through the streets
carrying torches and violently clashing
with counter protesters
one neo-nazi plowed a car into a crowd
killing heather heyer liz signs narrowly
escaped injury during the clash and is
the lead plaintiff in today's case i
don't think i will ever not be scared
the plaintiffs allege social media posts
and text messages prove the defendant's
intent to engage in violence leading up
to the rally in two social media posts
i'm ready to crack skulls fight until
the last drop i hope they will support
my right to free speech the defendants
have argued that there was no conspiracy
leading up to the rally
and that they had a first amendment
right to protest we know that what
happened four years ago is not an
isolated incident but really has
previewed so much of the extremism
that's followed amy spatolnik's
organization integrity first for america
is providing support to signs and other
victims in the case there was such a
lack of accountability for the violent
extremism we saw on display here and
that's what this case is about making
clear that if you are part of this
violent hate if you conspire to bring
violence to attack people based on their
race their religion their willingness to
defend the rights of others you will
face consequences
and with cases like these security is
always a concern and it will be a
concern today and going forward in this
case michelle
all right thank you jeff and i just have
to say it's like been four years hard to
believe on that but this was really the
first incident of its kind we'd seen of
this kind of right-wing extremism yeah
and it raises a fascinating legal
question about whether if you bring
these people together these powers these
forces and they are unleashed in a
deadly direction are you the organizer
responsible yeah and there's a clear
distinction between a non-violent
protest and what we saw four years ago
that's for sure